- Big investment banks and money managers
didn't get much right in
their predictions for 2023.
Most were betting on a recession,
rate cuts from the federal reserve
and a middling year from
the US stock market.
Instead, the S&P 500 gained nearly 25%.
The Fed raised rates, and the US economy
grew with the fastest pace in years.
So what are the big
banks betting on in 2024?
I'm gonna tell you what
Wall Street is predicting
for the economy, what they're
expecting from the Fed,
and how they're expecting the stock market
to perform this year.
Let's get into it.
More than two-thirds of the economists
at large financial institutions
that do business directly
with the Fed said they expected the US
to have a recession in 2023.
We detailed a couple of
the recession predictions
on this channel.
Some analysts are saying
that the recession
that most of Wall Street
predicted would hit this year
hasn't been avoided.
It's just been delayed.
But it didn't happen.
And in 2024, recession calls
are few and far between
among economists and market forecasters.
Most big banks expect the US
economy to grow by around 2%
in line with its long-term trend.
Citi is one of the few big banks
predicting a recession this year,
but even they aren't predicting
the stock market will fall.
The bank is calling for
the S&P 500 to end 2024
just under 10% higher
than where it end in 2023.
Deutsche Bank is also predicting
a US recession this year.
The firm says the effects
from the Fed's unprecedented
rate hiking cycle in 2023
will bring about a mild
recession this year.
But they're also predicting that US stocks
rise by nearly 10%.
Most big banks are predicting the Fed
will be cutting interest rates this year.
A few believe it's because
the US will have a recession,
but most are predicting
that with inflation falling
below 3% at the end of
2023, it will get close
to the Fed's 2% target this year.
And that will mean that
the US Central Bank
can lower interest rates
to loosen up the economy.
When the Fed cuts rates, it
is historically given a boost
to stock and bond prices.
That's expected to happen this year
with most analysts predicting
positive stock returns.
At the end of 2023, market
strategists predicted
that the S&P 500 would rise to 5,132.
That's about 10% higher than
where the index closed the year
according to FactSet.
That was based on a collection
of median target price
estimates for all the companies
in the benchmark US stock index.
The last survey of 2023 by
Bank of America Securities
found that fund managers
were the most optimistic
in any month since January, 2022,
and the most bullish on
stocks since February, 2022.
Some of the predictions
for the best market returns
come from firms like Fundstrat
and Yardeni Research,
which both called for the US
to avoid a recession last year.
Some of the lowest market expectations
come from J.P. Morgan and Morgan Stanley.
J.P. Morgan sees a challenging
backdrop for markets overall
and expects that companies will struggle
to increase their profits significantly.
And Morgan Stanley is
expecting an increase
in the number of companies
defaulting on their loans.
Big picture, most banks
see solid economic growth,
lower inflation, and higher
stock prices this year,
which sounds pretty good.
But remember, big bank's
predictions for 2023
didn't exactly pan out.
So don't sleep.